hey guys I'm just here with Eddie dan is
completely gone he's too sick and he's
gone home so you stuck with us but uh we
do have the top five stories of the week
for you
all right so let's start off with one of
the biggest things that you guys which
having a bout that we brought up in news
this week the PS 5 was predicted by
weather security analyst Michael Pachter
to come out in 2019 and you guys had a
lot of different opinions on whether
this is a real prediction whether it had
any legs and what do you think Eddie so
I guess we just want him to lay it on
the table and say you know like analyst
predictions while they do you know hold
the weight he is looking at a number of
things to make those predictions it's
you know historical trends
it could be conversations he's actually
had with companies but it could also be
just you know his own kind of
speculation so we just wanted to make
sure that everyone understands that this
is not obviously an official
announcement there's still a lot of you
know time to come in between what he
said that might happen so it's a very
fluid situation but I mean obviously
Sony is in the console business so they
they will make another console and I
think the thing that he said that really
got people talking to was that he
predicted it would be a half step
similar to the how ps4 Pro compared to
the ps4 so instead of a full
generational swap he predicted would be
somewhere in the middle which is kind of
what we're seeing with the Xbox one
explore it'll play Xbox one games but it
is still in more powerful consoles so it
wouldn't be surprising to see Sony go
down that path but still a lot of
details still to be announced all right
so next up we hate to talk about
Delaney's but neither Cooney chair was
delayed this week the head of level 5
the developer Akihiro Hino did apologize
deeply for having to delay it but they
said they want to deliver like the
proper full name attorney to experience
and unfortunately that is resulting in a
delay it was due to come out on November
10 of this yet and now it's coming out
on January 19 he also wanted to clear
something up apparently responded to a
question at a threeway he implied it was
gonna be
to plan in the sequel they will not face
and they gonna say it's gonna be a full
single-player experience near
multiplayer ps4 PC as we've known from
before and you know game delays happen
and usually it's in the best interest of
the game so you know so another big
piece of news this week was Star Wars
Battlefront 2 is getting an open beta
and happening in October so the beta
begins October 6th and runs through
October 9th but if you pre-order the
game you get in two days early and this
is gonna be on all platforms ps4 PC and
Xbox one and when you get in there
you're gonna be able to try out a 40
player multiplayer match the map takes
place on thieve which is the capital of
Naboo so you know some familiar
locations there from from the movies
that you might be aware of there's also
gonna be a mode called Starfighter
assault this is you know space battles
more info coming on this in August
during games come and another thing to
note is that there will be four new
classes assault heavy officer and
specialist that you'll get to try out
for the very first time you ever use
pshome Eddie I did it was a strange you
know pretty fun opportunity experience
Korean avatar and it's basically like a
big social space you wonder around this
on ps3 and in dreams that people who
made it up bringing it back as part of
any game atom universe it's called
aurora and apparently it's been rebuilt
with like all the original pshome assets
so it's something that people can use
again which is extremely strange it's
completely free - so no barrier
eventually if you just want to jump in
and check it out yeah it's apparently
got everything from the original
including its flirting archipelago and
the mini game over on ax that's pretty
sweet yeah there there are some paid
elements if you want like a private
space I I mean I never personally used
it I was more of a hub of
so if you're into second life and pshome
you know this is 2017 is a weird year so
we already knew that
overwatch was gonna be an eSports thing
and it sounds like it really is taking
off was it dropped a lot of details and
we are more sleepy does yeah earlier
this week Blizzard made the official
announcement of the first seven team
owners and among them are Robert Kraft
who's a billionaire who owns the New
England Patriots and Jeff Wilpon who
owns the venture capital firm that owns
the New York Mets so there are some huge
names from traditional sports and they
are investing there not to disclosing
their investment levels but we saw a
figure floating around of twenty million
dollars to get a team going so if that's
accurate then you know this is obviously
no small figure that they're putting
together and this league is going to be
there are seven teams right now but we
sat down with the overwatch Lee
commissioner Nate Mainzer and he told us
they have plans to grow the league he
didn't give a specific memory said
they're working with partners to find
you know the right number the right
balance like traditional sports leagues
will be base salaries for players we
asked an answer if there was going to be
a players union he said he stopped short
of confirming anything that'll be up to
the players if they want to unionize but
it is very very big moment for you know
over watching sports and then just
competitive gaming in general because
this is the gonna be the first time that
there will be a city based structure for
competitive eSports tournaments so we
might be looking back on this
announcement as you know a very
watershed moment for eSports and if
you're looking for more overwatch news
be sure to check out the site we have a
gallery right now with all of the new
doom fists victory poses and skins all
the ones we've seen so far so check that
out
awesome well that's everything we've got
for you guys the Dan Mayo may not be
back on Monday depending on how sick he
is but uh thanks for joining me Eddie
thanks for having me thanks for being
with us again for all AI news episodes
this week and we will see you next week
[Music]